2017 has already seen some great video game
releases, with hits like The Legend of Zelda:
Breath of the Wild, Resident Evil 7, and Horizon:
Zero Dawn grabbing the headlines.
But while the mainstream gaming media has
been focused on picking apart every minor
flaw in Mass Effect: Andromeda, there have
also been a ton of great smaller releases
that have slipped through the cracks, overshadowed
by the big guns.
Until now.
Grab your controller and fire up your Twitch
stream, because here's a look at the best
games you've already missed in 2017.
Night in the Woods
Infinite Fall's Night in the Woods is a deep
and stylish meandering through the little
things in life, with a healthy dose of musing
on the nature of God and the meaning of human
existence.
It also explores the boredom of working class
America while presenting an engaging mystery
and allowing players to explore mini-games
and side missions galore.
And the beautifully designed dream sequences,
filled with fear, emptiness, and the search
for meaning, are not to be missed.
Clocking in at 10 awesome free-to-play hours,
Night in the Woods is one game that shouldn't
be missed.
Statik
If you're looking for something a little different,
welcome to Statik, a puzzle-solving virtual
reality experience in which you don't know
where you are, who you're with, or why your
hands are locked inside increasingly difficult
puzzle boxes.
The puzzles themselves strike just the right
balance between trickiness and ease, while
the atmosphere in which you're tasked with
solving them is downright creepy.
The first generation of virtual reality consoles
have been criticized for not having enough
killer games to justify the cost, but innovative
and fun experiences like Statik are quickly
changing that notion.
Try it and see for yourself!
Wonder Boy: The Dragon's Trap
Available for Switch and the PS4, Wonder Boy:
The Dragon's Trap is a perfect example of
how to make a 30-year-old game great in 2017.
A remake of a 1989 game, Wonder Boy: The Dragon's
Trap has been revamped with a beautiful and
cartoony art style, while retaining the original
platformer's story and mechanics.
As a bonus, players can even choose to play
the original version instead if they want,
which is pretty much the ultimate in retro
gaming.
The Sexy Brutale
Cursed to remain trapped in a never-ending
masquerade ball, players in The Sexy Brutale
have to try to prevent a series of murders
which take place on a continual, time-bending
loop.
To solve the mystery, players must master
the essence of the game's time-looping mechanic,
in addition to flexing their investigative
muscles in ways the classic board game Clue
could only dream about.
The Sexy Brutale isn't very long, but after
you've solved the last murder, you'll be left
itching for more.
Hidden Folks
Take one look at this game's artistic style
and it's impossible not to be intrigued.
Combining classic Where's Waldo style hunting
fun with gorgeous, hand-drawn visuals in a
one-of-a-kind gameplay experience, Hidden
Folks is perfect for mobile phones while also
being right at home on PC and Mac.
The daydreamy landscapes are teeming with
activity, but as the title implies, much of
it is hidden, inviting you to explore the
game to discover its many secrets.
Be warned, though: once you start playing,
it's nearly impossible to stop, so don't boot
up Hidden Folks unless you have a lot of free
time available.
You're going to need it.
TypeShift
If you're sick of word jumbles, crosswords,
or sudoku, don't worry.
You just found your new daily obsession in
the form of TypeShift, which gives you columns
of letters you have to arrange into words
until you've used up all of the letters available,
like a cross between Boggle and Tetris.
It's simple, but deceptively difficult.
Can you spell "addictive?"
Once you start playing Typeshift, you'll never
have to make eye contact with other people
on the bus ever again!
Candleman
With a unique combination of art direction
and gameplay, Candleman has already made a
name for itself as an innovative indie title
every curious gamer should try out.
You play a candleman, who can only stay lit
for 10 seconds on his quest for a distant
light.
The game's mechanics and story play with the
contrast between darkness and illumination,
using the interaction to traverse a range
of obstacles and environments.
Candleman is one of those little games that
sometimes gets overshadowed by bigger, louder,
more in your face titles.
But this is one game that refuses to hide
its light under a bushel.
Fire up Candleman and let your gaming light
shine!
Hollow Knight
If you ever wondered what Dark Souls would
look like if it were done Metroid style, then
Hollow Knight is the game for you.
With incredible hand drawn graphics, breathtaking
music, and innovative sound effects, Hollow
Knight provides hours of entertainment as
you explore an environment filled with puzzles,
secret areas, and over 30 tough boss battles.
For fans of side-scrolling adventure, it just
doesn't get any more stylish - or fun - than
Hollow Knight.
Plus, there are already whole communities
devoted to figuring out the game's rich and
mysterious lore.
So what are you waiting for?
Get out there and do… whatever it is you're
doing.
She Remembered Caterpillars
Featuring a hand-drawn art style reminiscent
of a children's book created under the influence
of psychedelic mushrooms, this color based
puzzle game investigates the bond between
parent and child in unexpected and strange
ways.
A mind-bending experience with a touch of
creepiness and more than a heap of weirdness,
She Remembered Caterpillars is worth checking
out for anyone who is looking for something
a little different.
Detention
Set in 1960s Taiwan, Detention incorporates
elements of Taiwanese and Chinese culture
and mythology into a disturbing experience
that PC Gamer said is, quote, "the closest
a game has come to capturing the essence of
the original Silent Hill games in years."
For most gamers, that should be about all
you need to know to give this one a shot.
But be warned: just like Silent Hill, Detention
is a creepy, and sometimes downright terrifying
game that will haunt you long after you finally
set down the controller.
You know what they say: In Taiwan, the game
finishes you.
Splitter Critters
There's nothing quite as exciting as a game
that re-imagines gameplay itself.
Splitter Critters does just that.
The premise is simple: you're trying to help
critters find the exit to the level.
But you don't actually control the critters.
Instead, with a swipe of your finger you can
tear the screen apart and then reposition
the pieces to form a new level layout.
And since different types of critters have
different movement patterns, figuring out
the best way to play god requires a lot of
strategy.
Good luck.
Because those critters are counting on you.
Blaster Master Zero
Taking players on a retro-trip to the golden
days of the Nintendo Entertainment System,
Blaster Master Zero is an 8-bit side-scrolling
and top-down action-adventure game.
Reinventing the classic 1988 title Blaster
Master, this new edition keeps all the fun
of the original while updating gameplay with
three decades worth of innovation, making
for a familiar yet fresh gameplay experience
that makes us giddy with nostalgic bliss.
Torment: Tides of Numenera
Most RPGs these days are heavy on the combat
and light on the narrative.
Torment: Tides of Numenera goes the other
way, emphasizing story over collecting loot,
resulting in a game that's closer to an interactive
fantasy novel than just another hack and slash
orc massacre.
For old school RPG enthusiasts who love nearly
infinite dialogue trees, or for fans of the
classic Choose Your Own Adventure novels,
Tides of Numenera is the game you've been
waiting for.
Robo Recall
Afraid of an artificial-intelligence-filled
future?
Want to kill every robot you see?
Oculus Rift owners, rejoice, because Robo
Recall is just the robot-slaying, first-person,
virtual-reality experience you've been looking
for.
One of the first games to really show the
potential of the Oculus Touch controllers,
Robo Recall features optimized game play to
compliment beautiful art direction in one
of the best shooting galleries ever devised.
So give it a shot… no pun intended.
Tales of Berseria
Out in Japan since August of 2016, the acclaimed
RPG Tales of Berseria finally came westward
in 2017.
Despite praise from fans and critics alike,
though, Tales of Berseria has been heavily
overshadowed by more hyped, triple-A games.
Don't let that fool you, though.
With an unusually dark and mature storyline,
and some truly memorable characters, Tales
of Berseria features over 50 hours of engrossing
gameplay.
Plus, it allows you to experience firsthand
what it might be like to live inside an anime
world.
If there's one thing Japan knows how to do,
it's create incredible RPG adventures, so
if you're a fan of the genre, or simply want
to find out what all the fuss is about, give
Tales of Berseria a try.
You won't regret it.
Bleed 2
There seems to be no shortage of retro-inspired
pixel-art games these days, but don't dismiss
Bleed 2 as just another Contra clone.
With buttery smooth controls, charming pixelated
animation, and boss battles that are truly
epic, Bleed 2 manages to be accessible to
everyone while still rewarding those who wish
to dive deeper into its intricacies.
It's also more forgiving than most Contra-inspired
games, particularly on lower difficulty levels,
and can be completed in roughly two hours,
so you really have no excuse not to give this
one a shot.
Pinball FX2: Star Wars Pinball - Rogue One
Pinball fans will enjoy this game.
Fans of Star Wars: Rogue One will enjoy this
game.
Heck, everyone who enjoys fun will like Star
Wars Pinball: Rogue One.
It features tight mechanics, silky smooth
gameplay, and fantastic physics—with sound
effects and movie quotes galore.
Even casual fans of the film will appreciate
the level of detail and creativity that has
gone into this table, whether it be the black
Deathtrooper firing lasers all over the place
during a multiball, or Jyn giving the smackdown
to a stormtrooper.
So are you a pinball wizard - or a pinball
Jedi?
Put your virtual quarter in and find out.
Thimbleweed Park
If you like your adventures to be of the point-and-click
variety, look no further than the surefire
under-the-radar hit Thimbleweed Park.
It's not just a point-and-click adventure
game, mind you.
According to Polygon developer Whitney Reynolds,
it's actually "a point-and-click adventure
game about point-and-click adventure games,"
with meta references to spiritual predecessors
like Maniac Mansion.
Fans of the genre would have to be true maniacs
to not give this one a go.
Just don't play it if you're easily offended.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!